let's have a look at this as is usually
the case when someone asks me a question
no one else are you questioned at 30 Abe
will be or state no of course not let's
go straight for the hospital so what I'm
gonna do is most of this this question
it is quite pedestrian somberness so
discreet Barbara felt a little bit but I
will talk to you because you obviously
need to understand the earlier parts to
even like recognize why the last part is
a questionable so let's have a look
question 20 consider the function of not
even a living for you consider this
function 1/6 of x squared minus 4x plus
24 recognize what kind of shape disease
they even tell you right off the bat
it's a parabola so the first part is can
you tell me what it looks like okay so
just in case you don't have it in your
head here we go there's the parabola and
the first thing you learn it now you do
this about it is it has no X intercepts
and the reason why is because it's
positive definite I mean there's lots of
ways to see that but you can immediately
notice like one of the ways you can look
at something and take what something is
going to be up here you see you're
adding 24 men right so then of course
with the one-sixth has that effect of
raising you up by 4 units right but of
course you can just think about the
numbers if that's too close for you say
B squared is 16 4 AC is going to be 96
so of course it's gonna take off right B
squared take before I say negative
that's why you get positive okay so
there it is that's the problem
then we go back to the question and it
says stay the largest domain containing
utterly positive numbers for which M X
has an inverse function f inverse okay
so suppose it's a parabola we need to
think about this domain restriction
because when you go to a an inverse
function what's the issue with that
parabola why is it a problem
correct so it fails the horizontal line
test but way you with another technical
way of saying this by the way is that
this is not a one-to-one function okay
so what do one function means for every
x value
there's only Y and for every Y value
there's only one X right now for every X
there is only one one right like I can
give you x equals anything and you only
so this is the vertical line test right
so it passes that it's a function but
because it fails the horizontal line
test if I said to you why who's ten well
there are two x's that will match that
right so this is not one-to-one okay
so fast that so we have to say all right
what restriction would you like and they
never say well I want the positive side
we know that we could take care of the
left-hand path all the right hand half
then what the right half so you
basically have to come back to your
graph and say if i zoom in a little bit
you'll see the scale yeah that we far
enough so you can see and you can verify
this is you calculus or cousins in
pavlok you just find the vertex using
the axis of symmetry
there's x equals 5 4 3 2 x equals 2 is
your axis of symmetry okay so therefore
X is greater than or equal to 2 that's
the domain of interesting ok that'll
give me an adventure okay so then says
sketch f inverse on your diagram from
Part A and stated dummy
ok now I'm gonna do a bit of a hack here
and I want you guys to be able to follow
along with me so if you have a computer
you can see like if I have a function
nor right like if I gave you this this
one I have had a look at a few to us I
can do I can work out what the
university is just by algebra right I
can say well in order to get the inverse
I'm going to swap what you put it
upwards my X's and Y's like so and then
I just do my usual thing to make expert
make wireless object okay so then you go
through and that's fine now what you
have a look at this guy you could have
caught go through the whole process but
it's a bit of waste time to think about
like what it looks like there
any point ask you to find an equation of
this thing they just say well can you
tell me where it is when you graph now
all I've done here you can see this is
the first step right
you see I've swapped my inputs and
outputs so of course if i graph this
there's my boys at square knot square
there we go there's my sideways parabola
right but of course that's not M inverse
because that's not a function so copying
this function so what do ya know just be
careful I wanna restrict the domain on
this guy the orange graph which means I
need to restrict the range of the
inverse function okay so you guys just
told me X is greater than 2 is my
original domain restriction so that
corresponds to a range restriction of is
greater than 3 so let's let's go ahead
and put that in so I don't know if you
know how to put restrictions in desmos
yet so let me show you um if you go down
to the bottom left hand corner and
invoke this alphabetical keyboard
you guys are those I undo this all the
time like that's not just because I like
curly braces even though I do it's
because curly braces are our convention
for stating domains or ranges so if you
pop the curly braces in okay and then
you come back to your original keyboard
what did you say the retribution was
again y greater than or equal to 2 then
there it is and of course I'm so you can
see what I've typed in over there that's
the whole thing and you can see the
restriction that's resulted okay so
that's good so far so good I'm gonna
come back to the original question now
I've sketched it can you tell me the
domain how you guys are talking tell me
the value necessarily but how am I gonna
find it let's have a look this is the
domain now I'm interesting here right
you remember I got the range restriction
by looking at the domain restriction of
this guy that I wanted so how will I
find the domain of this
yeah I'm gonna find the range of the
original gun which is whatever whatever
that is I would have said why I've
created that's for this of this hey X is
greater than that like if you graph it
freehand it's obviously going to be more
difficult okay so I'm sort of taking
advantage of the fact that this is there
um I'm just thinking I don't think it's
instrumentals for the question in this
case whether there is it deserves or not
my battery
I create of course a y equals x and
because there's a solution see if I play
this guy again because there are two
solutions between y equals x and this
sky right the places where those two
intersect is the same place where you're
correct so if if the original question
was like you have a look at this
question right clearly like they try to
get to this right so then not that
worried about like you get if it goes
exactly right okay but whether the
question determinate here no this is the
whole thing and I want these two at the
same time then is that's probably the
important feature I want to know where
they just say okay so let's go ahead you
can see an interesting way either fig
it's going to end up affecting at least
for me the way I do this
so how you're gonna do this eunice all
this equals this and you'll get into
damage which um like the inverse and the
original only
yeah okay so the short answer in the
short answer is yes and I what do you
think that geometrically why okay the
whole idea of going from a function to
its inverse geometrically the sooner we
began the or any of the outros right was
to take the reflection across y equals x
and go like that okay and that's why you
turn your heads and you can see the
symmetry right so therefore it stands
its reason if there's a point that is of
take this wagon if there is a point that
is all in my line of reflection itself
that when when I reflect it it's going
to stay exactly where it is okay so
therefore where is the inverse gonna be
for the original for continue and the
answer is still here because I reflect
it and it doesn't take me anywhere okay
whereas if I'm off of my y equals x line
you're fled this guy he comes at behave
you're reflects this guy comes over here
right but when you reflect something
that's on the line itself you stay
so therefore like and this is part of
the point of me highlighting it like
don't go ahead and do the contour of
this right you should be doing the
algebra all solve for this equals that I
don't think so I was trying to
understand it and they were like oh but
sometimes it can be like different
variations of y equals negative x and
then like I was really whatever we are
thinking of is yeah okay this is
actually the question the kid asked me
before sometimes depending on you know
with the trig function we look
like there's this periodicity so you get
copies and copies and copies so if you
are solving something like an Origin y
equals close aversive cousins you like I
it's it's read like Bobby feel ok that
we'd Papa T is actually like different
graphs and we're just under main
restrictions so we get this point if you
take away all of the restrictions right
instead of saying okay let's do because
instead of getting just these parts
right if I take away all the
restrictions which is exactly what
happens if you do something like this ok
no board if you just x + y make bit
variables i can change to go any way
they want suddenly this line doesn't
just start here and stop there it just
goes and so does this one
and so does every other one in fact what
you end up getting is this kind of
isometric Korean and they just sort of
go on forever okay so if I then go ahead
and take the inverse of that video
inverse of this isn't right number one
first number two outside the course
number three there's a whole bunch of
points on here that aren't y equals x
that when i take the inverse which is
ruining my physics line and then reflect
that's going to intersect with the
original that's probably cuz the
original is like everywhere like I was
just saying okay this looks like some
time but it'll intersect with itself its
function will intercept with its inverse
on places that are y equals x will die
exactly right that's that's exactly my
point which is why it's outside you know
okay so all functions will
the functions this inside that's right
our very best relations that's another
okay